[Music]
[Applause]
right boy
it was over the old guard was wiped out
against
[Music]
in our series show
we saw there was no way the unblocked
witness book
as fate would have it the tide turns in
our favorite game
a new intern
blowing us
there was only one
fuss
[Music]
cooee
their employer now results
enemies became friends
didn't trust anybody the philosophy of
at the top of the food chain
[Music]
[Music]
hunts in packs
[Applause]
all of Skull and Bones there are
soulless empires there are greedy
trading companies and of course ruthless
pirate games sailing the seas but there
are no heroes hello my name is Justin
fair and creative director at Ubisoft
Singapore and for the past year my team
and I have been anxiously awaiting at
this moment to invite you our fans to
join the hunt here at e3 2018 piracy is
dead in the Caribbean the Empire is
crushing all those who oppose them so
your next big score the Indian Ocean
home to the richest trade routes in the
world where merchant ships carry cargo
worth over 10 billion dollars a year and
you you're gonna steal every last
[ __ ] coin first you need a target you
pick up intel on a heavily guarded
frigate fat with african diamonds mint
for the grand mogul of india that
treasure will help you claw your way to
the top to become the pirate that no
Empire can take down second you must
know your hunting ground or reactive an
evolving world is reflected in what we
call fortunes presented to you by
tallied the fortune-teller now fortunes
reveal changes in factions weather and
the trade routes themselves today tell
g'd reveals favorable winds that means
more merchants to rob but also more
competition and now I'm proud to share
with you the essence of skullenbones a
shared world where every player
encounter matters will you fight or will
you ally this is what we call the
hunting grounds
alright pirates let's head to the
hideout and have a great III
[Applause]
[Music]
this hidden pirate den provides
everything you need for your next strike
from your shipyard be choose the black
horns the
the strong winds will boost its speed
giving his pattering rhyme a devastating
punch
next choose the right crew and gear for
the mission ahead
deme cannons are slow loading but deadly
at short-range rockets are blazing fast
a deal powerful damage from every angle
with everything loaded
the winds are strong in the day is clear
more merchants trouble but also more
arrival pirates are looking for a quick
school
according to your Intel the convoy said
he passed a portuguese fort taking
advantage of the strong winds that fort
is too strong to simply sail past its
cannons can blast you out of the water
we need to find a way to sneak by before
the convoy slips away
fortunately deception is another tool in
the pirate arsenal for these black
guards
disguised as a Portuguese merchants you
tried to creep past the fort captain if
we engage they will see through our guys
this island provides perfect cover for a
surprise attack
gloves the optimal cause for an
intercept meeting your sales for speed
we want to catch your victim off-guard
is she bad
ships traded to the border
[Applause]
while ship sighted Portuguese frigate I
your attack had alerted a powerful
Portuguese warship
at the helm is a Commodore to have to
handle on your own
even worse you could lose your loot
and they need help and you need it fast
are the captains of anti-joke or four
against one should even the odd
your site forms a tight squadron using a
coordinated battle plan
the enemy strikes first
the first ship goes down breaking a
formation
commodore turns his cannons Oh
you raise your fire
your allies maneuver opposition the
royal fortune axes at tank drawing the
Commodores fire it unleashes its special
ability the siege mode once anchored it
can fire its cannons without limits
slips into position that is powerful
it's special ability delivers eight
shots in a single blast
cruising the answer at Crystal
it's up to you to land the killing blow
is one
but the glitter of gold can turn new
allies into deadly enemies
for there is no honor among thieves
[Applause]